[Music]
pay for my name's James Duke I mean our
strategic cloud engineering group in our
personal so just thing I'm here was
right I'm Cheyenne I'm also a strategic
cloud engineer in the Google cloud
professional services and we're gonna
talk to you today a little bit about the
practical guide to wouldn't call it
practical guides of mobilizing
applications for containers if folks
have questions there is a Dory please
feel free to use it if you open your app
you should have a link to it from the
next app if you fire questions into
there we'll come back at the end and
address those questions will also take
live questions we have them have a
microphone so as we said it's the end of
the day right so we'll take a fairly
summary fairly casual experience we're
just gonna have a chat it's like you
guys are watching our chat and we're
talking through this process a little
bit so what are our goals I'd sorry
rules are really three things we want to
understand what modern applications look
like what are some of the terms or buzz
words you hear associated with modern
applications like containers micro
services cloud native and so on and so
forth and why they're important why do
what do they mean for your business
why would you want to build applications
that are cloud native or that run as
containers and so on and so forth and
then the real meat of our session is in
how how can you get get your application
Mike migrated over so it's it uses some
of those design patterns that we'll
discuss so those are really the three
main goals of this session yeah in the
first two we'll kind of level state a
little bit you know we'll talk about the
definitions of some of these things
there pros and cons and that kind of
stuff and then we'll talk about you what
does a journey was a journey to a modern
application look like today so let's
start with what so shared what is a
container so yes so containers you hear
a lot of buzz words associated with
containers and they're lightweight
portable fast and so on and so forth so
let's look at what do this really what
does this really mean so containers in
themselves are really about two
technologies first it's a way of
packaging your application and all of
its depend
c--'s into what into a single image and
then the second capability is the
ability to run that image in an isolated
set of processes so those are sort of
really the two main things that
containers provide you they let you
package everything that your application
needs into one single image and then
provide you a mechanism to run that
image in an isolated manner so that's
really what this is and the key term
here is process so containers run as
processes so just like when you start
something on your computer it starts a
process in the background it runs as a
process containers run the same way and
containers are a group of processes that
sort of work together to provide some
functionality that you need so who he
has built and deployed a container
sheriff Hanson okay not bad let's talk
about half I would say who's used some
kind of container orchestration system
kubernetes most are slow per stack okay
about third okay that's good that's good
that helps us answers with the level
saying for where we go through this so
for those of you who've deployed it
you'll be very familiar with this it
gives you this nice nice packaging you
get the application you get the
dependencies for those who are less
familiar with it this may be a new
concept but the idea is that I now I
only depend on an environment to execute
the container I don't have to care about
bringing him live libraries and ask to
care by bringing in dependencies because
I've packaged them all up into my
container so let's look at how
containers and some other ways of
running your application sort of compare
so if you might be familiar with this
kind of a diagram which shows what
running applications on a on a shared
host looks like and that's basically the
host provides the kernel and it provides
also the libraries that your
applications need and then all of the
applications that are running on that
host share that those that kernel and
the libraries the challenge with this
kind of setup is since the libraries are
shared you have to be really careful
which version of which write library is
installed on that VM and for that reason
a lot of the time people actually run
one application per host so they're on
one application they bring all the
dependencies that they need they bring
it to that host configure the host
the right kind of environment for that
application and then run it there but in
many ways is very convenient right
because we now have a kind of a logical
grouping of our application applications
should I say the problem is there's not
really there's kind of minimal
boundaries between those applications
you can do some stuff with sandboxing
but generally speaking in this model
those applications they're all in a
shared space and so I don't have any
security minimal security boundaries
between those things so that doesn't
help me when those applications should
be isolated from one another so if we go
up the stack a little bit we think the
next thing we might think about is VMs
right well why don't we take those
applications those dependencies and then
we can fit multiple single host
application servers onto one physical
machine people talk about bin packing
right we're now we're now using we're
now more effectively using more of that
that machines resources because we have
more things running than we were able to
before but the trade-off here of course
is the libraries are not common so now
and not just the libraries the kernel so
now in a given host given physical
machine I'm running multiple kernels and
there's a huge overhead well there is an
overhead for having done that right each
kernel there will use its own set of
resources CPU memory and its boot up
time is a factor
every time I boot a kernel there is
there is a time penalty in doing so okay
modern especially in Linux place one
modern kernels can boot very quickly but
there's still one penalty there because
you still have to do it it can take a
matter of minutes for a for a VM to boot
up and it does provide a lot of
isolation as we were saying but the cost
is that it's not very flexible if you
need to resize a VM if you need to give
it more resources you have to really
essentially rebuild that we have so
that's where people went to container
technology Google was one of the
pioneers in that technology all of our
workloads internally run as containers
predominantly so the containers provide
isolation within one host so instead of
breaking up that host into individual
VMs we use some of the mechanisms that
are available in the kernel in the Linux
kernel to isolate a set of processes
from another set of processes
each of those set is a container the
great thing is that they share the same
kernel so once the host has booted up
the kernel has loaded there's no more
delay in launching these containers and
starting each of these containers is
like running a process as soon as you
type in a command on your on your laptop
for example the application comes up
quickly it doesn't have to wait for your
machine to boot up so so that's some of
the advantages of using containers yeah
it totally removes that kernel boot time
and I was talking about for the VMS
right it uses the same kernel the kernel
is already running you just spin up
another process and the reason the
reason we're kind of doubling down on
that is when we're talking a meaning
about was a cloud native computing look
like one of the most important parts is
scalability and to me when someone says
I'm gonna go to a cloud native
application that means it's going to be
very scalable and vm's they can scale
very well but imagine a scenario let's
say well like an unnamed company who may
or may not have released a new product
this morning imagine that your press
release generated a bunch of traffic to
your your application you need to be at
a response very very quickly if you have
to wait for vm4 kernels to boot up that
might result if even if it is only a
minute or two that may result in a poor
experience for your users and that's
especially concerning if it's the first
time they're experiencing your system
there's nothing worse than sitting on a
loading screen the first time you ever
use a product to turn you away from
using it so the concern with containers
that's not a problem right if you want
to spin I mean within reason right it
depends on how many containers you can
fit on a given kernel but within reason
it allows you to scale much much much
faster because you don't have that boot
time penalty one drawback with with
containers is that there's even though
there's less dependency on the host
there's still a dependency on the kernel
since the kernel is sheared you have to
target a particular kernel but the good
thing is these days linux kernel is
pretty standard so a lot of applications
target the linux kernel and can run as
containers so with that in mind let's
revisit some of those buzzwords so to
see if you have a better appreciation of
what that means
so as we described it containers are
lightweight and it's true because they
they don't have the overhead of creating
a full VM virtual machine when you
8:1 you have to provide the host OS
image on it libraries and everything
that you need to run your application
and in a container you only put in what
you need right you you're able to
specify just the bare minimum set of
things that the application needs in
order to do its job so you can end up
with containers that are very very very
small from an actual disk spice
perspective and they are portable
because you're you're bringing all your
dependencies with you so any libraries
that you need you're bringing with you
and all you need on the host is really
the kernel and some runtime that can run
your container and those are pretty
standard these days the container
runtimes and it's pretty easy to install
that on any host so that that what makes
your your containers portable and if you
you know it's it not just portable from
one VM to the other but it's also
portable across environments you can run
the same container on Prem and on you
know on any sort of cloud provider as
well and that yeah you caught the
keynote this morning see the keynote
speech yeah so you saw our glorious
leaders talking about and those and what
anthos brings to the table so in a world
where you have a and those fundamentally
builds on the construct of a container
right if you have a world where you have
that hybrid multi cloud environment once
your application is container I was
moving it between those clouds or
between those environments is very very
very straightforward so if you have a
platform where you can orchestrate all
of your security your networking your
monitoring with your service mesh and
everything and your configuration
management all across those different
environments the question is not can I
move it the question is where would be
the optimal place for that particular
workload or that particular application
and which so when we say portable that's
really what we're talking about it's not
moving it from one VM to the to the
other it's much broader than that it's
how do I put this application so it's as
close to my user as possible well maybe
it's something as simple as this one
particular platform is more cost
effective for the type of workload
documenting whatever it might be it
gives you the power to choose to run
your application wherever you want it's
this old phrase right build once run
anyway
and then they start fast so as we said
since there's no overhead of starting a
VM your containers start as processes
would on an ordinary host so the boot
they start in I shouldn't say boot but
they start in a matter of seconds and as
long as your process needs to start
taking traffic that's all it takes for
it to do that so let's quickly demo one
you know just see how the containers
look running from you know the host
point of view as well as the container
itself so here I have a Google cloud VM
and I'm going to run a container image
that I've created and pushed to one of
the container registries that we have so
I'm going to use the docker run command
to run this container and once I run
that it has started that container over
here so when it was yes it was no ko no
boots on so since I had downloaded the
image earlier on this VM it didn't even
take time to to sort of start that so
let's look at the you know if I look at
what images are running this is the
image that's been running and it's been
up 18 seconds since I just started it
and so let's look at what the process
tree looks like from you know on the VM
so as you can see this is the VM so I'm
looking at the host I'm looking at all
the processes that are running so this
is everything that's running on the host
and part of that tree you will see is
the is is the the container D which is
our container runtime and the nginx
process that I just started as a
container so you'll see this is just one
set of processes within the other
processes that are running on that host
so there's nothing special from the
hosts point of view for these processes
other than it's just grouped together
and it has certain boundaries associated
with that next what I can do is I can
look inside that container and I can you
know I can I can attach myself to that
container and see what the process tree
looks like from within that container so
what I can do is I can start another
command inside that
beside that container by using the exact
amount so you see the command prompt has
changed here and now I am in the context
of that container this may look very
similar to a VM when you login to a VM
you know you have a certain command
prompt and so on so if I if I look at
the process tree within the container
you'll see it's a very limited set of
processes it doesn't even see the
container D process that's the parent or
the container shim it only sees the
nginx processes that I started and since
I'm running the PS command and I just
started the the bhl you see that as well
so from the container point of view it
has the whole host available to itself
it doesn't see any other processes it
cannot interact with any other processes
so that's where that isolation comes in
but from the point of view of the host
you can see pretty much everything
that's running on the host so that's
what the difference is there's no magic
here is just processes that have been
sort of put in this sand box or a
container that you see in actual fact
that the Linux kernel has no concept of
a container it's a it's a purely user
space construct so it's just built up of
processes the sandbox from one another
the reason the reason we're going into
some detail is because as you can see
should I hit right there as do you have
root on this machine are you route here
I might be I'm not sure so I can look
inside all of that process tree yeah
that is to say if you have sufficient
permissions on the host then any
containers that are running in that are
potentially visible to you right so when
we talk about security and we talk about
how to secure a cluster and how to run
secure clusters it's not just about the
containers it's not just about the
namespaces it's also about the operating
system level access as well all right we
can switch back to the slides
so let's look at some of the other
terminology that we talked about so what
are micro-services again the the things
you see associated with micro-services
are that they're loosely coupled they're
frying sort of fine-grained they provide
some minimal set of functionality that
that you know that's useful and they
make you more agile and and you know
they should be testable on their own and
so on and so forth you who's who's built
or deployed micro-services okay about
quarter I would say okay okay so for
those of you who you've done it like
what was the cause of thinking was the
reasoning that so I'm gonna someone
shout out white why go micro-services
yes extract business logic from your
monolith excellent excellent we got one
more break up the monolith to improve
scalability also excellent all of these
things they are absolutely the value of
the micro services so let's let's dig
into two of those and use those to
explain the buzzword so separate the
business logic from the monolith all in
a moment we'll talk about why use these
things but the teal the short version of
that is these are tools and tools should
be used to solve business problems
technology just by itself well very cool
and I think it's obviously a passion of
mine it doesn't solve real world
problems by being cool technology it's
those real-world problems by being
applied in the right way to real world
problems and so to the point of
extracting the business logic having
everything tied up in one thing it makes
it very difficult for you to focus on
the things are important for your
business or for your customers
businesses because there's so much are
the staff wrapped around it in this
giant sprawling in some cases decades
old piece of software and it becomes
very difficult to say ok well it's now
2019 I need to do some some stuff
because the markets change my
competitors are changed I have a new
idea and it makes it very difficult to
do that when it comes with all the other
craft and the same is true of the
scaling piece right if I have a mic a
monolith and I suddenly have the success
disaster scenario I described earlier I
get a hundred or a thousand x traffic
that I do on a usually usual basis to
scale that I have to either absorb it in
the existing model if
or recreate instances of a monolith and
manage traffic between those instances
and that is a very very can be a very
very painful thing to do because often
those monoliths are not designed to spin
up quickly they have a bunch of
dependencies in some cases they run on
specific hardware there's all sorts of
reasons why that beacon can become very
difficult but if you break each part of
that monolith out into its own micro
service now I can scale each one of
those services independently I can
modify and update each one of those
independently to change the business
logic to add new features in summary it
makes us more agile
because it allows us to respond to
changing market conditions and indeed
changing technology conditions as well
and testing the same thing once you have
a smaller piece of functionality that
you have to test your releases are
quicker because you don't have to worry
about testing all the features that
you've built into this big monolith so
so I hope with these you have a better
understanding of why the industry has
been moving towards micro services net
next let's look at the cloud native so
cloud native you know means built for
the cloud or sort of born in the cloud
if you will and typically you hear that
if you if you want to build for the
cloud you have to use containers you
have to be a micro services architecture
and what it will give you is quicker
releases and scalability and all that
some of these reasons we saw earlier you
know when we looked at containers you
saw that containers are easy to sort of
deploy from one place to the other you
don't have to prepare the infrastructure
as much to run your container because
you're bringing all the bits that you
need with you so you're building the
bits and the infrastructure is just
providing the compute and other
resources that you need but it is
important to note the the three things
are different right a containerized
application is not necessarily the same
as so microsomes is architecture they
often go hand in hand but it's not
necessarily true and you could do both
of those things and still not be cloud
native or you could be cloud native and
do neither of those things the three are
not necessarily the same we do typically
see them coming together though the
majority certainly from what we seen
with our customers and in them in the
broader IT in computing industry we have
seen typically a cloud native
application displays a microphone
as architecture and it's usually
containerized especially when we look at
something like anthos right which will
naturally leads towards a containerized
and microservices model and all of the
three things together is where we see
that we kind of see the future of our
field going yeah so that's what now why
so we touched on this a little bit I'm
shy why should we use containers so I
see containers and micro-services and
all these as enabling technologies so
they do not bring necessarily benefit in
themselves they enable you to sort of
reap the benefits of the modern
infrastructure that's available in the
cloud so that's that's how you should
think about it this is not a means this
is not the end in itself it's a means to
an end and you get all of the benefits
that we talked about that you get from
containers you get the portability you
know the the the scaling up and down
fast scaling up and down and portability
and all that with that and it opens up a
lot of options for you you can run the
same container in a VM you can run it in
a in a platform like kubernetes or you
can run it even in serverless
platforms like a cloud run and so on and
similarly micro services and containers
together provide some of the some of the
benefits that we talked about you can
scale up your application quick quicker
but again your application has to be
built in such a way still that it can be
scaled up easily and we'll see that when
we look at how as to how to think about
that when you're when you're designing
your application or as you're converting
your monolith into a micro services or a
modern architecture so what do we want
to be about what the options are for
where we can we can run these containers
yeah and quicker release cycles are
basically since you're you're it's not a
big application that you're releasing
your micro services are smaller so it's
easier to manage the releases when you
have if you think about it when you
start off a project it's easy to sort of
you know iterate on the code as the code
base grows bigger then it becomes
challenging so keeping it in micro
services
forces you sort of to keep that codebase
smaller as you're separating out your
business logic into individual repos and
individual release cycles so what that
gives you is that once you have the
image once you've built the image the
right way you can now run it in in many
different types of infrastructure and
here's some examples with just once
you've built your image just hello world
in this example you with one command you
can run it you can pick the runtime that
you want and you can deploy the same
image in any of these products that
Google cloud platform offers yes so very
simple right four different commands and
you have the same container running in
four different infrastructures or four
different platforms should I say and so
when we talk about portability like this
is what it looks like in practice now in
reality this is a little bit of a trite
example all right because most people
aren't pushing a single container with a
single command more than likely it would
be in some kind of orchestration
platform but the same thing holds true
across the different orchestration
platforms too so here you can look at
you know you can't just at random pick
you know one day I'm gonna run my app in
App Engine or cloud run we good yeah you
could I wouldn't recommend that you can
once you have the container built but
here's you know some guidance on how you
can pick the right runtime and the way
to look at it is it's sort of a
continuum on one end you have pure
infrastructure that gives you a lot of
flexibility of how you want to manage
that infrastructure for example VMs you
can pick the image that you want to
deploy on your VM you can you can
configure it the way you want to you can
you know put libraries that you want to
on it and then you can run your
container on it and that's one option
and what you're getting is a lot of
control what you're giving up is you or
what you're I guess signing up for I
should say is now you have to maintain
that man since you created a custom VM
you have to make sure that any updates
that are needed are applied to that and
as you move in the stack to the to the
right you start giving up that control
you're letting the the platform or your
cloud host
provider take on some of those
responsibilities of operational you know
aspects of your infrastructure and
you're focusing more and more on just
your workload but your workload has to
conform to the to sort of the api's or
standards that that platform expects it
to have so that's that's the trade-off
involved in moving from left to the
right of this and eventually the sort of
the new sort of Nirvana is serverless
where you're not worried about your
infrastructure at all and you're letting
your cloud provider provide the
infrastructure for you based on your
workload and all your all your providing
is again your image which is exactly the
bits that you need the software that you
need and nothing extra and you're
letting your hosting provider provide
the underlying infrastructure for you
absolutely
oK we've teased it enough we've done all
the background on the level saying let's
jump into how we might actually do this
right because it seems like a daunting
task you face with a giant monolith like
I said it could be decades old it's a
daunting daunting task to take on and
say okay I want to actually change this
where do I start
so we've kind of well we didn't come up
with this approach it's been around for
a while but we found we wanted to share
with you some things today that we found
to be effective when we've done this
with our own customers and as a
suggestion for ways that you folks could
do this thing so first step you need a
list you need to know what do you have
what does it look like where is it
running what does it do what
technologies is it does it involve one
or it's dependencies and more to the
point what group is it in so classifying
it on the basis of a number of things so
we we came up with these three groups
right yeah so we start off with
stateless applications as you might
imagine stateless applications tend to
be the easiest group to deal with and so
we tend to deal with them first things
like web front-ends not existing
services maybe maybe they micro maybe or
not and existing API is that just taking
data transform and and send out that
data anything that has no stake anything
that takes the request gives a response
but doesn't rely on
kind of underlying state the Greek group
all those together and they tend to be
our first movers that tends to be our
first place to go web front-ends in
particular seemed to be a very popular
approach part of the reason for this is
you want this first mover to be
non-trivial you don't necessarily want
it to be the number one revenue
generated for the business because the
first time you do this is a bit of a
learning curve but you do want it to be
something that's meaningful and that has
some kind of real-world use because if
you just start with a hello world
application that nobody uses it doesn't
really prove anything out so often we'll
find their web front-ends whilst they
are you know in the critical path for a
lot of user journeys they tend not to be
well hopefully intend not to be too
complicated and and and I'll stateless
usually lend themselves very well to
this first quip yeah
in the second group temporary state what
do we mean by temporary state so
temporary state is something where an
application when it starts up it starts
building up at state it doesn't sort of
persist that state between startups and
a typical example is a caching
application Redis or memcache or
anything like that when it starts up it
doesn't have any state but as people put
items in that cache it starts building
up and if you had to restart that it's
not a catastrophic event you can you can
you can restart it but you'll suffer
some loss in response time or there
might be some errors that you might see
as it's restarting similarly
applications that sort of take on
different role once they start up for
example you could have a master and a
slave when they start up they are all
the same but then this somehow
coordinate to pick one master things
like that Redis has that and there are
other examples of that as well so this
is sort of the second group that we've
come up with and we calling a temporary
state because again that state is not
persistent across restarts it's
something that it acquires as it's
running so these these can be great
second movers because again you have
once you once you have the knowledge of
what does it take to run applications as
container
in a more dynamic environment you are
ready to take on the challenging of how
to build that state dynamically how can
you elect a master when you know when
existing master dies without someone
manually intervening and so on or how
can you build up maybe the cash from
other replicas and and sort of
redistribute cash as as one of the
replicas dies or something like that so
that's why this is our second group that
you should look at and then thirdly and
finally stateful applications databases
file servers and raw storage it's not
impossible in fact it's very doable to
move stateful applications into a
container containerized or
micro-services architecture but it's
more complicated than the prior ones
typically typically many especially more
legacy databases are necessary set up to
just add more rep add more nodes to get
more capacity right they have they have
a concept of Master and slave but in a
very different way they're often not
dynamically deciding and voting and
promoting new masters but many time and
so these these really these probably
won't want to be the last thing that you
would consider largely because they
benefit the least they benefit the least
from from migrating to this new paradigm
and they have the least amount of the
least amount of benefit for most
complexity to actually change them as
well and how many of you have tried
scaling my sequel database for example
you can't just add a replica and expect
it to work out of the box so it's it
requires some sort of manual you know
design and decisions that you have to do
that you can't just say oh I need
another my sequel instance and just add
it there and go from there
so that's why these are more difficult
to just do sort of container eyes and
the benefit isn't as much there because
you won't be scaling these up and down
dynamically to begin with so second so
first step list in group second step
containerized parts of the application
in most cases you probably don't want to
go well it's possible to go to a big
bang approach tourists say say hey you
know what we're gonna take a whole
company out of our regular release
schedule for six weeks three weeks and
we're gonna go I just do the whole thing
we're gonna take the whole application
wrap out the containers and release it
out lovely and practice very very very
difficult to do in sorry lovely in
theory very very difficult to do in
practice in practice in most cases for
most real-world scenarios you'll want to
do this one step at a time
so once you have your list and your
priority your groupings and your
priorities then it becomes about finding
parts of that application to move to
those containers first so some examples
the most basic example of all of this is
take them on with and put it into a
container right it's the fastest way and
technically you now have a containerized
workload right check the box yes I can
do containers it's quick to deploy and
actually can be automated which we'll
come to in a second this allows you to
prove out the concept allows you to get
comfortable with the technology and
depending on the nature of the monolith
may allow some some scaling that wasn't
possible before you don't really get the
full benefit having said that it can be
a very worthwhile exercise both from a
learning perspective but also from I
need to move right now perspective and
you know the reality is many times in
the projects that we've seen there is
some kind of compelling event like
Friday Cyber Monday a holiday a sports
event or even something as mundane as a
data center lease expiry I have to get
out of my data center by April 29th
whatever it might be so this is part of
sort of the the lift and shift sort of
kind of migration where you're lifting
the application just container izing it
and shifting it to your - as a container
to the cloud and this can be done in
many times there are there you know ways
to do this automatically in fact if you
saw the you know the keynote this
morning you saw an example of an app
being migrated from from a VM into
kubernetes engine running as containers
so there's anthos migrate which helps
you do this automatically so
you can do it manually as well but there
are instances where you can just use the
automated service like anthos to to do
it for you as well so again this can be
a good start to your journey so the next
the next approach would be okay so let's
let's think about how we would migrate
some parts of a three-tier application
right so in many cases the way you would
do this you will be put this behind a
load balancer right but a load balancer
in front you may already have one
pulling behind the Google cloud load
balancer and then we can look at the app
front-end and the app backend remember
we said these are the pieces that don't
necessarily store straight maybe that
the back end might be one of our semi
state applications the front end would
typically be no state and then what we
can do is wrap those up in containers
and now we can scale those tiers
individually so if we have that success
disaster scenario I can rapidly scale up
my front end to handle those those
requests without necessarily having to
do the same scaling to my back-end now
of course you may end up with contention
that a database in a scenario but at
least allows you to respond at the very
least allows you to respond with a we're
working on it we'll get back to you
instead of just returning a four oh four
or five or three one thing to clarify is
that dread box does not show one
container boundary you want to the the
white boxes are really containers so you
want to run the front-end separately in
a separate container and the backend
separately and this is a nice transition
from a monolith as well this could be
the first step at breaking up a monolith
typically the web sort of the web front
and part of a monolith is easy to break
out so you can start with that and you
can separate that out modernize it using
some new technology and and you know and
leave the rest of the monolith running
as the backend for that front-end so
this could be a good starting point on
your journey we still know although I
they're right we still don't get all the
benefits so what can we go to next over
yeah a little bit more of the benefits
we were talking about so we can start to
think about a transitional
micro-services architecture we're still
kind of mostly in a monolith mode here
we
we're kind of dipping our toes in the
water it okay we're gonna say well okay
one small part of that my life we're
gonna break out and build into a
separate service and in some places this
might actually be completely new
functionality we've actually seen both
work where we've had customers that have
built a new function or new feature as a
new micro service and left everything
else in a monolith we've also seen folks
who said well actually you know what
this one particular part of my model if
I can carve that out and recreate that
same functionality that same feature in
a separate service you might now likely
that means you have dead code right
there's probably code left in that
legacy back in that now long no longer
operates and that introduces some
problems right you may have code
duplication so maybe some cecal deck to
remove that out later later later in
time it may be possible to remove it
there and then that's really a very
dependent on the particular application
that we're working with but the basic
principle goes take a piece out move it
over there and now that piece can scale
very easily and we don't have to really
affect the existing monolith there's a
lot of there's very little appetite for
changing the monolith in a lot of the
customers we work with especially things
that are in a more regulated industry or
in a more traditional enterprise type
space where they don't really want to
touch it because it has been running
that way for ten years and they're very
nervous about changes breaking him so
when we do it like this we don't have to
touch that monolith we can leave it
leave it well alone so there's very
little risk to the business and this is
a great way of reducing risk as you're
migrating because taking small steps
making small changes reduces your risk
you don't have to worry about making a
big change and upselling something that
you didn't even know might go wrong when
you start you know peeling things the
other thing is when you take small steps
it's easier to sort of estimate what you
would need to do and and you can apply
your learnings to the next steps that
you will take as well so the first time
you're building a micro service you
might be learning a lot and you can
apply those learnings as you build more
and more micro services if you start
with four or five you might you know
you'll be repeating the same mistakes
across four or five work streams that
you could avoid by doing
one change at a time so in the next step
is let's add an API gateway and now the
API gateway becomes the arbiter of where
all traffic goes so anytime a request
comes in it can come directly from the
load balancer in some cases or it can
come from the the application front-end
now the API gateway decides where
traffic goes so minute very minimal
change as well no change is required to
the front end except pointing a
different IP address or service name and
now the API gateway gets to the slide
okay which which back-end do I need to
send this request to is this something
that I need to send over to the back end
the legacy back-end the monolith or is
this something like I can send to one of
these fancy new micro services that we
have and this is particularly powerful
because you think about this as you add
service b c d e and so on now the only
piece that has to change to support
those new services is the api gateway so
it becomes a single point of
configuration that's basically routing
your traffic from monolith or micro
service so it gives you that flexibility
of where to send that traffic and it
hides that detail of what micro services
you actually have running behind the
scenes from your clients from the
consumers of those services so they
don't have to know that now you've
migrated service B or C over and you're
not no longer calling the monolith it
can also provide some added benefits for
example if you wanted to add TLS or SSL
as it's also called like you wanted to
secure the communication the API gateway
can typically you can add that
functionality very easily using the API
gateway API gateways support you know
providing TLS it can also provide rate
limiting or it can have other features
like if it if it detects you know some
failures and stuff it can provide sort
of you know certain braking and other
things so depending on the API gateway
of your choice it can add a lot of
features to all your services with very
little cost all of these features are
built into the API gateway that you
might have so you get all those benefits
with that so in finally there is the
true micro-services the end goal that
we've been sure
all along you'll see that the API
gateway still a key component eventually
we could get to a place where we don't
need that we can have something like a
service mesh for this year or something
like that to control all the
communications but we we still consider
it a true micro services place even
though we have the API gateway involved
and at this point we've basically taken
the previous one and start spinning up
these extra services right so there's be
service service service B through
service in and now we've got all that
good stuff everything we talked about in
Y micro services and containerization a
cloud native designer gets what gets our
business we can scale every service in
Davitt individually each one has its own
life cycle so you know we we go B we've
seen customers we've gone from releasing
once a quarter to releasing sixty or a
hundred times a day because now they can
release small small things very very
very very quickly and that pace of
innovation can improve so much just by
moving to this type of model the
downside of course it's harder to manage
yes right or different to manage because
if you're our company that's used to
dealing with a monolith it requires a
change of thinking because now I've got
multiple services with multiple teams
are responsible for maintaining those
services I probably need to create some
kind of centralized CI CD system some
kind of configuration management
platform all these are kind of overheads
which go into orchestrating all these
micro services but when this happens
when you get to this beautiful state
because you have so much agility and
ability to innovate in the application
development teams the company or the
business is able to spend so much more
of its resources on the thing that
actually makes money because running the
perfect kubernetes cluster doesn't make
money well I mean maybe for Google not
for not for most customers whereas being
able to innovate and being agile and
respond to the market that's where the
true business value isn't now does
anybody recognize that pattern you know
know what it's called I didn't like I
wish I'd made this up but I didn't this
is the strangler back so this is another
yourselves
sounds a bit macabre doesn't it actually
comes from a tree analogy and so the
principal goes like this if you have a
big old well-established tree we're in
California so let's call it a redwood a
big redwood tree and then you have which
represents the monolith and then you
have a bunch of vines growing up around
that tree as those vines become more and
more mature and stronger and stronger
and harder and harder there comes a
point in time at which they are now
providing more structural integrity than
the tree around which they are growing
if that tree dies and rots away the
structure remains and that's basically
what we're trying to do here we are
trying to build microservices around the
monoliths such that we've made the
monolith obsolete and we can shut it
down and remove it and throw it away and
never shed a tear for ever again and so
that's the basic premise of the
strangler pattern and it gives you that
flexibility and it gives you an its
gradual or partial what path forward so
you don't have to do everything in one
gun and as we mentioned your
organizational processes would need to
change as well as you move from one type
of architecture to the other see icd is
one thing we mentioned just increasing
developer velocity will have its own
challenges when you have multiple
releases going out imagine doing you
know tens of releases instead of one
release a quarter or whatever you're
used to so this allows you to gradually
change your posture from a traditional
organization to a more agile
microservices based organization as well
with with less risk alright finally
profit the end of the day that's well
we're all that's what business is all
about right three easy steps categorize
migrate small parts build up to the
final thing and profit all right so some
useful resources we have we are very
blessed here to have a wonderful set of
labs please go find out find the
hands-on labs session you've got all
sorts of fancy machinery there to go try
out these particular labs we highly
recommend the gke best practices quick
labs quest tried on a team put a lot
working to building those out and they
kind of guide you through some of these
best practices we've talked about here
yeah and they guide you there are labs
that start from just building your first
container and deploying it to all the
way to you know running you know
hardening those containers adding
security or cluster as well as going all
the way to maybe deploying a service
mesh and so on and so forth you can pick
the you know the expertise level that
you have and you can find a quest or lab
related to to that expertise level and
go from there we also have a bunch of
open source code samples and templates
the URL is there please check them out
about nearly 20 repos now I think which
show essentially how you would do this
in production and they are templates so
you can grab copy iterate on and deploy
into your environment to get you started
very very quickly with some of these
things and these are open source that
link will take you to a github a bunch
of github repos that you can you're free
to use there under apache license and
open source
[Music]